a car pulled up next to me the window
wound down i got chucked a package into
my car which was
yeah big and then i got chucked 400
pounding rolled up notes
to which point i'm sat in a car then
thinking
you know what i've just done
[Music]
what was the training like to become a
prison officer
um
looking back on it now
not substantial enough um but it was all
engineered around the classroom
basically
and
learning you know via powerpoint etc
there's no prisoner facing there's no
there's no environment that you can
replicate when you go onto a wing for
the first time and there's 130
young men there
and there's nothing that can replicate
that
i remember opening the doors to the wing
and all of a sudden the thing i remember
most is the noise the noise was
something else and to see 120 lads
basically running wild
and it was
well it was breathtaking um i worked
primarily in lancaster farms which is
a young offender institute in lancaster
which houses
um
lads from manchester and liverpool
mainly and there's a few kind of local
lads mixed in but mainly the big gangs
from manchester and liverpool
they all come into lancaster farms and
then they cross fire there at that point
i felt scared at that point i questioned
what i'd done
and i didn't let anyone know because at
the time the ego and the brevard all
took over
but yeah inside i was i was worried and
i knew i'd made a probably not the best
decision
the first 18 months there was no issues
whatsoever
the second eighth well the second period
of my employment there i was drinking
heavily massively
um to try and
i don't know maybe i just couldn't cope
with it you know the stress was it was
it was horrible so i think over a period
of time the prisoners would have
probably picked up on the fact that i
wasn't doing too well i remember one day
i knew this lad's
dad
was ill
and one of the cleaners came to me and
said can you go another word with
ex-prisoner and i said yeah no problem
so i've gone into the cell
and the lad was in in bits in tears on
the bed um
saying that he needed to speak to his
dad urgently as his dad wasn't well he's
got no phone credit please please please
can you bring me a mobile phone and
to which i've said no
i've been getting gone off my dinner
what i should have done at that point is
reported that to the prison but i didn't
i just kept it in my head
went off to play football at dinner came
back
and
same again unlock
all the prisoners go off the wing to
work to education to do whatever
and
the same instance again that's still in
tears please will you bring me a mobile
phone in
now this has been on my mind all dinner
time
and he said to me as i was sat on the
end of the bed to him
i'll give you 400 pounds to bring me one
more ball falling
and i don't know why at that point i
walked out of the cell again didn't tell
anyone didn't say anything to him i just
walked out
and he asked me again
and
and i don't know why but
i said yeah
and i was then passed
a mobile phone number
on a little piece of paper and told to
ring the number when i left work
and
i've driven out of the city thinking i
you know i was some kind of mastermind
went to use a telephone box
and run the number
and i was asked where i was i said right
well i'm 10 minutes from junction
whatever
a car pulled up next to me the window
wound down
i got asked are you lee i said yeah
and then there was two lads in a car
one of them had like a hoodie on and
whatnot and then all i got i got chucked
a package into my car which was
yeah big and then i got chucked 400
pound in rolled up notes
to which point i'm sat in a card and
thinking
you know what i've just done
all the while i've got in my mind how am
i going to get this
pack of this phone this package into the
prison in the morning
in prisons the prison i worked i think
in my stint of three and a half years i
think it was actually searched
three or four times so the balance of
probability was in my favor but
again obviously it was still a big worry
so i stuffed it down my pants in the
morning
so obviously pulling into the car park
i'm trying to look around the car part
thinking is this some kind of ploy is it
a
you know a setup
so i just decided to go for it
everything looked normal everything felt
normal i just wanted to get it out of my
house gone into the second door where it
is the point of no return
you know there's big signs on the thing
you will face ten years in jail if you
bring contraband past this
you know point
and just as i've walked
down as if i was going down onto my wing
and the lad that i was doing it with was
stood at the bars waiting for me
as if to say is it so i just nodded
walked into the prison i've then gone
into the cell
to which he was sat on the end of the
bed he said have you got it i said yes
and at that point there's a few people
knocking about walked out of the cell
walked back in later on
took it out and just said there you go
don't ask me again
now
looking back on it
that's exactly how it was
but i knew full well in my mind then i'd
been
turned i'd been turned by cash
albeit 400 pounds it's nothing really i
knew that i'd got away with it
or in my mind i thought it got away with
it
so i agreed to do it again
um
to which i've now earned now on a
thousand pounds in
two smuggles call it
i become quickly addicted to the cash
and the stupidity around it and the
adrenaline i think it was
it was stupid
so what exactly were you smuggling apart
from mobile phones initially
mobile phones i never had anything to do
with the packages as in they were given
to me sealed ready done
after three times of doing it i realized
that
there was probably well i knew there was
cannabis in it i could smell the
cannabis the first two
i mean were all fairly savvy people i
had a smell of it i couldn't tell you
exactly what was in it and neither did i
really want to know because i didn't
want to get involved with it
um
but the third package i definitely knew
there was cannabis in there
so how many
packages did you smuggle in total do you
reckon in total
i don't know maybe
a year's worth of a year's worth of two
a week maybe
something like that
where are you scared of doing that
i think
i become
numb to it and blase to it because also
as well you know
the guilt and the shame involved you're
going home i mean i'll be your cash rich
but
you're a no one really aren't you
everybody can see through you because
i've become a recluse i didn't want to
meet anyone i didn't socialize with
anyone from the prison stop seeing my
mates because i just become
insular into what i was doing
was there any support in place for the
prison officers
absolutely not
they i know they're changing it they
have changed dramatically over the past
five to ten years they're starting
prison officers on somewhat ridiculous
like 18 000 pounds you can go and earn
that working in gold burrito it's it's
bizarre because corruption will always
be there but when you're putting a
bigger temptation like that and not
giving them the proper training
and obviously not making them aware then
it's it's
putting young people at risk they didn't
even have such a thing as a like a bully
officer or a
uh what you call it a mentor back in my
day you you were just chucked on a wing
and it is like i said before it is
pretty intimidating
if you're not that kind of you've got to
be a special person i think to do that
job clearly clearly i wasn't good you
know i wasn't um suitable for it but
yeah i no i don't think um
i don't think there was much support
back then
so how did you get caught
i've got two three packages at my house
and i thought
i need to get rid of these quick and
then i'm done
i've gone into the jail the first door's
gone back
usual story there was nothing untoward
and just as i've walked
down as if i was going down onto my wing
there's a door open at the side
and it's my
wing manager and he said can i have a
word i said yeah no problem
now obviously at that point that that
wasn't untoward because sometimes you
would have a detailed do you know if
there'd been a problem the night before
if there'd have been a cell farm you
might get a detail on your way in so i
wasn't worried at that point
um
he said can you step in here a minute i
need to ask you something i don't want
to ask you have you got anything on you
that you shouldn't have
i said no
and he said right okay
he said i need to take you upstairs
there's a search team waiting for you
um
north west search team and i was like
right and i knew obviously at that point
it was up
i've walked up the stairs there's two
dogs three or four officers a governor
um
and i've walked towards the dogs and i
thought what am i doing you know and i
just said look with all you know respect
i'm gonna give you what you want so i
said if you can just allow me to go into
my thing and i give them i said look i'm
sorry
there it is and he said well we're still
gonna have to search you anyway you know
the protocol i said yeah that's fine at
that point i just literally sat at the
desk and thought thank god it's over
i don't have to make that decision
anymore somebody's taking it out of my
hands
um
so then taken down to the police station
and at that point i'm still in full
prisoner officer uniform so epileps i
pretty much look like a policeman
so i've been taken into the cells and
obviously all the other prisoners are
now seeing what they believe is a copper
put into the cells so they were banging
on the doors you know there's a there's
a pig in here there's there
and it was just again the noise levels
were unreal
stupidly enough i was seeing another
girl on my wing at the time
and
she had been caught she'd run straight
to the government and said i'm not
involved with doing what he's doing
however we have been sleeping together
so my girlfriend's got wind of this her
mum's got wind of this i've spent all
day in the police cells obviously not
knowing what's going on or not knowing
what's waiting for me outside i mean how
ridiculous is that pretty much just
ruined everything that i ever had and i
was on bail for for about a year
and that's when things really started to
unravel
i'd started taking cocaine
to
alleviate what was going on
um so i would drink in the day
take cocaine in the night
or or vice versa and then drink it was
just that one big vicious cycle of
trying to numb what was coming really
trying to numb the pain and the guilt
what was the prison sentence you got
uh four years
the girl picked me up in the van who i
knew in the prison van and i said where
you taking me and she said oh we're
going to shrewsbury and i think this was
probably the most poignant moment in my
prison sentence in the sense of when
reality hit i went through reception
signed me in and i said i'm lee davis
and you know the prisoner
the prison officer just looked at me and
went yeah we know who you are i remember
speaking to my mum and i just crumbled
um
thankfully at that point there was no
more prisoners around but i think when
you hear someone's voice when you've
gone through what you've gone through
that day and you hear your mum's voice
and she says are you all right
and you kind of say yeah but you know
you're not and i think at that point i
just that was the first time that i'd
properly crumbled i think and it was the
only time really imprisoned that i did
mentally crumble
because after that i put up like a
i think you have to you have to act
because
that's what prison is it's all about
acting
who people think you might be or who
you know you don't want to get
ie you know the prisoners and whatnot
you don't want to be seen as weak you
don't want to be seen as a pushover so
you have to become almost an actor
how would other prisoners treat an
ex-prison guard among them
i think it all depends on
how you carry yourself
if you look in the eyes
of the crime that i committed
technically in the criminal eyes i was
on their side
um i was actually okay but i know it can
go very wrong
having said that i did trying i
obviously kept my head down and didn't
get involved in anything
did you witness any instances when it
went really wrong
in my first jail there was three
policemen two prison officers
all on various different offences
the policeman has followed me from my
closed conditions prison
into the open prison so therefore you're
in just in belays
you can get up to what you want really
you're in like an raf camp
and
they've put him in the same cell as me
the policeman i'm working three days in
the prison helping prisoners with admin
court applications etc etc
in in what they call the hub
going out two days a week to college to
retrain to be an electrician
so i'm sat in my cell one day
kettle was on a dinner
fortune i don't know loose women or
whatever
and there's a knock on the door
and the hatch is open bang bang bang and
it's the two lads i'll work within the
hub
right all right and i thought oh christ
what's going on here so let us in let us
in sort of sat in the under my bed and
he said right we know about you you're a
next prison officer
i said right so i'm now thinking what's
coming
uh right well we're not too bothered
about that we've known about that the
problem is that the lad you're sharing a
room with is an ex-policeman
i said all right i mean i knew but
you know obviously i didn't want to let
i said all right not only that he's the
next drugs officer and he's been having
lads off going out to
drug raids
taking half back to the station taking
half for the from themselves and for
profit so technically having drug
dealers off
and lads have recognized him in here and
tonight you need to be off this belay
i said what do you mean i said tonight
just make sure you're not in this room
tonight because we don't want you
getting involved with what's going to
happen
and did that
because i know that if i go and tell the
prison
i know that's me
i know that's me
um either being transported out or
i was going to lose my college course i
mean that was what was retraining to be
my future
so i'd seen this lad and he's got family
he's got three daughters and all i could
see was his family and his wife in
visits in the old prison and i thought
now's the right time to make a right
decision
you know this might i'm gonna know it's
not gonna
write what i've done wrong but there are
certain times in life where you need to
make the right decision
it can go wrong it would have gone wrong
but thankfully i'd stopped it
how does it feel to be around so much
violence on daily basis
do you know i actually think i think
i went off adrenaline
i think because
looking back on it now because i'd
worked in the prison
and the prison i worked in was quite
full on and violent as in you mean we
all know what 21 year old lads are like
especially when you've got two rival
gangs from cities
in the prison i worked in before dinner
time you could be attending 10 alarm
bells so before you've even sat down for
a cup of coffee
you're rolling around the floor with six
lads wanting to knock lumps out of each
other so i think it probably prepared me
in a weird kind of way for prison life
i didn't find the prison part of it
mentally difficult
it was afterwards
is where i struggled
so what did you do to rebuild your life
after prison i really re-enrolled on the
electrical course
uh managed to scrape together some money
paid for it myself
re-trained to be an electrician
struggled to
find work as an electrician because
obviously at my age they're expecting
experience and whatnot so i did the odd
day on site here and there
so i started in this firm yet again
temporary contract and at this point i
got fed up declaring it and
i've never not got a job if i've gone
for an interview but i'd had that many
kind of little knockbacks and i knew
that i wasn't getting jobs because of it
you know very simple jobs very job jobs
i was well qualified for
i just wanted a chance you know i just
wanted to work again
so i've looked here and i thought i'm
not going to declare it
it's 30 miles from my house it's in a
place where people might not know me
i've started to work
everything's going fantastic probably
six weeks in
really well
they took three lads on
and we're all still there we're doing
very well decent money and i thought
yeah again back on track
this was on my birthday actually
so
i've gone in on the morning the shift
manager said have you got a minute
he said have you got an unspent
conviction
and i said ah yeah
he said is it on your phone i said no
he said lee why haven't i put it on your
phone
i saw it i kind of give him the story
anyway
it's
don't come about i said look i'm gonna
have to let you go because you know
you've not declared it on your form
obviously you've not been honest et
cetera et cetera and at that point i
thought
what do i have to do to get back into
this world
and after probably i'd say about two or
three months of not working i thought
i've i'm done with this i'm done with
this life
um
i couldn't
i couldn't get back to where i wanted to
be there was always games in my mind of
you'll never be what you was
all the guilt the guilt follows you so
much and that's been the worst part for
me the guilt will always follow you um
and i just thought
i i've tried it doing it legitimately
i've tried lying
i can't get back i can't get back to
where i want to be so unfortunately one
night i decided to end it thank god
the um
the hospital was was amazing
and
the paramedic team were
i didn't attempt
to do it ever again
because like i said it wasn't uh
that that was me i was done and dusted
you know it wasn't um a case of me doing
it just to get a bit of attention or to
to make someone aware because i think
everybody knew i was feeling anyway
so i did i haven't done it again and
thank god
are you cleaning up drugs now everything
alcohol and drugs were
my
kind of comfort
to a certain degree because i like i've
said i've never
until recently i've never spoke about i
couldn't speak to about you know all the
people i used to work with i couldn't
speak to them
[Music]
what's in the future now for you
um
i'm well obviously like i said i've
retrained to be an electrician so i'm
working and the prison service have been
in contact and asked if i would like to
get involved with
training new recruits and doing bits and
bobs for them so we're exploring that at
the moment so
maybe maybe that will be redemption
i mean it's been a long way around but
maybe that would be some kind of
redemption and i'm happy with that i'm
happy to carry on doing what i'm doing
um and who knows
you know my parents had
technically lost a son you know for a
certain period
i've lost my girlfriend
an intern i lost my house
you know all for the sake of what a few
quid
and over 11 years of of what it's taken
me to get back to
even if it was let's for instance say it
was 50 grand what's 50 grand over 11
years just for it's just stupidity
greed
that lad
wasn't on that wing very long he went to
the gym one day someone found out what
he'd done
um i remember the lad
and he hit him with a dumbbell
in the face he went to hospital and i
never saw him again